[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire ce week end ont
lieu les journées européennes du
patrimoine a rendez vous à ne pas
manquer l'exposition au lieu historique
nous ferons un tour d'horizon du
programme dans les yvelines découvrir le
centre ville muni d'un casque audio
c'est une nouveauté aux clayes-sous-bois
nous recevrons la responsable de
l'espace culturel philippe noiret pour
nous présenter la balade sonore enfin
nous parleront d'une exposition qui met
en avant des artistes atteints de
troubles psychiques l'occasion de
découvrir un univers original et changer
de regard sur ces maladies
les journées européennes du patrimoine
commence ce samedi 17 septembre à cette
occasion la commanderie des templiers
ouvre ses portes au public vous pourrez
découvrir ce lieu préservé
d'architecturé médiévale et surtout sa
chapelle elle sera accessible tout le
week-end les images de nicolas
kirillovitch
un écrin préserver d'architecturé
médiévale pour les journées européennes
du patrimoine la commanderie des
templiers dévoile ses secrets une
manière de découvrir ou redécouvrir ce
lieu emblématique du 12e siècle c est un
lieu en avait exceptionnelle du
territoire c'est pour ça qu'on rouvre
pour les journées du patrimoine
puisque en effet habituellement on est
ouvert le 1er dimanche du mois 1 /
programmation est donc ce n'est pas
accessible
en visite libre habituellement vous
pourrez vous rendre compte de ce qui
était une commanderie templière
avec ses 28 mètres de long et ses 8
mètres de large la chapelle impose son
architecture gothique au domaine datant
du xiiie siècle elle a été l'objet de
plusieurs restaurations celle de 1971
avait laissé les murs nus sans enduit ni
peinture la dernière en date a redonné
vie au décor ce qui est intéressant ici
c'est de la revoir après réouverture
donc à l'arrêt ouvert en 2012 après
restauration et vous pourrez découvrir
la restauration qui a été fait à savoir
la peinture les peintures murales
voilà et les vitraux qui ont été
nettoyées créé par l'ordre du templier
pour protéger les pèlerins en terre
sainte le site se visitera tout le week
end en entrée libre l'occasion de
replonger dans neuf siècles d'histoire
ce midi au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles le conseil départemental a
présenté le programme des journées du
patrimoine
animations ateliers conférences autant
d'activités prévues tour ce week-end
pour voyager autour de l'histoire des
yvelines pour la première fois le
département propose des visites
théâtralisées à l'hôtel du département
et au domaine de madame elisabeth un
spectacle vivant avec comédiens et
musiciens on écoute karl olive vice
président du conseil départemental
il était au micro de florennes parfait
via cette volonté de théâtraliser de
valoriser notre patrimoine
ce patrimoine au travers des petites
saynètes au travers une théâtralisation
que l'on doit à eric bouvron bien la
troupe d'éric rire 78 va pouvoir donner
un sens à cette visite en actions
qu'entraînera le mouvement et mouvements
qu'entraînera l'intérêt ce sera une des
clés de réussite est bien de séjourner
au pe européennes du patrimoine à
maurepas la médiathèque le phare a pris
un peu d'avancé sur les journées du
patrimoine depuis le 10 septembre elle
accueille une exposition sur les sauts
du moyen âge une manière de mieux
comprendre la période médiévale
découverte en images
il permettait d'authentifier un document
et faisait office de signature le sceau
du moyen-âge représentait son
propriétaire à maurepas une exposition
retrace histoire médiévale des yvelines
à travers cet objet symbolique on a pu
récupérer toute la collection des sauts
des yvelines et c'était tout l'intérêt
en fait de cette exposition c'était de
pouvoir présenter les sauts des
seigneurs des yvelines et en particulier
de la maison de montfort qui a occupé
une grande partie du territoire local on
en a un qui effectivement le premier set
simon de montfort qui est le sceau du
temps où il était ce qu'on appelle
griller des yvelines c'est lui qui avait
en charge en fait la gestion de la forêt
disney et donc c'est un soc auquel et se
fait représenter non pas comme un
chevalier mais comme filaments un
chasseur un simple chasseur alors qu'il
était déjà seigneur
le saut prenait la forme d'un cachet de
cire imprimé par une pièce en métal
accrochez vos documents initialement
réservé aux empereurs et au roi le droit
au saut se propage à l'ensemble de la
société médiévale au cours du xiiie
siècle progressivement marchand artisans
même les paysans acquièrent leur propre
saut c'est aussi la dimension sociale
qu'il faut voir derrière ses sauts c'est
de savoir effectivement dans quelle
mesure finalement on se faire
représenter sous tel ou tel aspect parce
que quelque part c'est de la publicité
aussi d'une certaine manière font pas
sur des illusions et donc c'est
intéressant pour le public de de se
confronter en fait à des images
médiévales qu'on n'a pas forcément
toujours l'habitude de voir installer en
partenariat avec l'association mort pas
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui une vingtaine de
ces représentations est à découvrir à la
médiathèque
le phare
[Musique]
aux clayes-sous-bois l'espace philippe
noiret nous propose de découvrir la
ville autrement muni d'un casque audio
le visiteur est invité à prendre part à
une balade sonore céline boutier
responsable de l'espace culturel
philippe noiret nous a rejoints pour
présenter son parcours bonjour céline un
jour alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une balade sonore alors une balade
sonore c'est un spectacle vraiment
novateur conçu par xavier giorgi qui est
artiste est à la fois informaticien dans
la musique il a créé une visite de la
ville des clayes-sous-bois avec les
récits de clis tiens donc sept personnes
ont été
ont pu
expliquer ce qu'ils vivent aux
clayes-sous-bois ce qu'ils ont vécu dans
leur enfance ce qu'ils connaissent de
l'histoire afin de raconter comme ça
tout au long d'une balade la vie des
claies aujourd'hui et hier merci
beaucoup c'est ligne pour tous ces
précisions on va juste un exemple
peut-être un peu plus parlant pour nos
téléspectateurs écoutez un extrait de
cette balade sonore sur des images du
lieu
vous y êtes des jeux donc c'est bon vous
êtes tous prennent pense oui
c'est bon juste avant de partir on va
faire un petit tour sur nous mêmes hop
je fais partie de l'équipe de ce
bâtiment d'ailleurs pour la petite
anecdote la première pierre a été posée
en octobre 2007 par la fille de monsieur
noir et voilà donc on a un centre
socioculturel qui comporte deux salles
de cinéma une salle polyvalente qui nous
permet de recevoir tout un tas de
spectacles concerts et on a également au
deuxième étage tout un tas de salles
dédiées aux associations chaque salle
porte un nom des films marquants de
philip man ray alors on l'a entendu ont
été justement devant l'espace philippe
noiret là c'était le début de la balade
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve après alors à
l'espace philippe noiret nous avons dès
ce soir le lancement du vernissage de
l'exposition de michel landi michel
landi est un des plus grands affichistes
français il a crié plus de mille
affiches en théâtre cinéma mais aussi
pour l'opéra et il sera parmi nous ce
soir pour lancer l'exposition qui aura
lieu jusqu'au 30 septembre et pour la
balade du coup on commence à l'espace
philippe noiret mais après qu'est ce
qu'on va découvrir il ya d'autres lieux
peut-être un peu emblématique de la
ville tout à fait on passera par la rue
henri proulx qui est la rue la plus
ancienne des claies on ira jusqu'au parc
de diane avec son arbre qui est vraiment
formidable enfin qui est remarquable
même c'est un arbre remarquable et qui
est cité comme tel et du coup l'objectif
de cette activité c'est de faire
redécouvrir un petit peu d e.on va pas
spécialement attention quand on se
balade en ville là c'est vraiment pour
faire les petits focus pour les
habitants oui c'est exactement ça
découvrir en famille car cette balade
peut se faire à plusieurs deux trois
quatre personnes de façon également
individuel on peut également réserver
pour des groupes pour des adolescents
des collégiens ou des lycéens donc
vraiment redécouvrir sa ville autrement
à la fois de façon très pédagogique
parce qu'on apprend plein de choses sur
sa ville mais de façon aussi assez
ludique alors vous l'avez dit mais c'est
essentiellement des clés siens qui donne
qui racontent leurs anecdotes qui font
ces commentaires c'est ça nous avons
sélectionné quelques quelques les siens
à qui nous avons proposé de
travailler sur cette heure sur ce projet
ambitieux
donc ils ont pu à la fois recherché des
anecdotes qu'ils avaient les uns et les
autres dans leur histoire personnelle il
y à une historienne également qui a
participé à cette balade donc ça nous
donne vraiment des faits très très
précis sur les clés alors combien de
temps dure ce parcours est-ce qu'il faut
être un bon marcheur pas du tout le
parcours dure 1h30 mais on va vraiment
très tranquillement donc c'est adapté
aux plus jeunes enfants comme aux
personnes âgées et comment est ce que
vous avez eu l'idée de mettre en place
cette balade sonore en anglais de lui
préciser mais elle commence demain à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
tout à fait nous avons souhaité créer
quelque chose d'un petit peu nouveau
d'avoir un spectacle finalement qu'ils
ne soient pas vu partout et qui puisse
être prolongé dans la durée puisque on
la sort à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine mais on pourra réaliser cette
balade à tout moment tout au long de
l'année aux horaires d'ouverture de
l'espace public noiret et c'est une
balade qui est gratuite pour terminer un
petit mot rapidement sur la
programmation de l'espace philippe
noiret vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
tout à l'heure michel landi l'exposition
qui a lieu dans vos locaux et qu'est ce
qui lie à d'autres là pour la pour la
saison qu'est ce qui nous attend alors
dès ce soir la présentation de saison va
dévoiler au grand public tous les
spectacles qui vont avoir lieu tout au
long de l'année mais d'ores et déjà je
peux vous parler du premier spectacle de
rentrée qui est la véritable histoire de
paul kress un magicien qui nous fait
vraiment tourné la tête avec miley tours
de cartes à ne pas louper ce sera le 1er
octobre et c'est au niveau des tarifs
des réservations comment ça se passe
alors vous pouvez réserver à l'espace
philippe noiret directement il reste des
places disponibles et le plein tarif est
à 10 euros pour ce spectacle merci
beaucoup c'est une boutique et pour
toutes ces informations alors je le
rappelle les casques audio pour la
balade sonore sont prêtés par l'espace
philippe noiret gratuitement pour tout
au long de l'année pardon aux jours et
aux horaires d'ouverture de la structure
on passe maintenant du côté de
versailles pour parler art créé il ya
quatre ans pour changer le regard porté
sur les personnes atteintes de maladies
psychiques l'association arc en art
convergence pardon organise jusqu'au 18
septembre une exposition intitulée
nature huit artistes exposent leurs
oeuvres à la galerie de l'école des
beaux-arts
regardez ce reportage de corinne fallait
montrer que les maladies psychiques
n'altère en rien la sensibilité et
l'intelligence artistique tel est
l'objectif de l'association art
convergence al exposé à versailles les
oeuvres de huit de ces artistes
l'occasion de découvrir leur univers
originaux à l'image des fleurs mandala
des zoos inspiré de la culture pop
japonaise en les réalisant
j'ai réussi à retrouver une espèce de
sérénité en fait j'ai eu beaucoup de
plaisir à les faire et j'ai ressenti
beaucoup de beaucoup d'émotions
positives allait faire en fait leur
capsule psychique et peut-être même un
moteur à la création dans le sens où les
personnes handicapées kp en tychique ont
souvent une sensibilité exacerbée en
fait et donc qui est propice à la
création autre univers fantasmagorique
celui de la jeune laura n'a et de son
minutieux travail pour constituer cet
univers aquatique réalisé avec 90 % de
matériaux de récupération
animaux marins real y côtoie personnages
imaginaires comme cette sirène fabriqué
à partir d'une poupée japonaise
unijambiste pour réaliser leurs travaux
pendant un an les artistes de
l'association étaient accompagnés par
des artistes professionnels
l'intérêt de l'association s'est aussi
de mettre en relation des des
collectivités locales avec des
structures de soins avec des artistes en
fait on a quand même un rôle de lien et
de passeurs aussi sec en fait enfin
c'est principalement ça notre notre
objectif jusqu'au 18 septembre les
oeuvres de ces huit artistes d'art
convergence seront confrontés à la vie
du public à la galerie de l'école des
beaux-arts une opportunité pour eux
d'exposer dans des conditions
professionnelles
ce samedi à 15 heures le groupe local de
solidarité saint quentin est vous invite
à un spectacle de danse indonésienne ça
se passe à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux 25 danseurs du
groupe c khardja gâte indonésien vous
feront découvrir leur culture la
participation est libre les fonds
récoltés serviront à acquérir un
logement pour venir en aide aux
personnes démunies on écoute françois
cheval et du groupe local de solidarité
nous en dire plus sur le programme
les indonésienne qui participent à ces
danses proviennent de
plusieurs endroits dont les îles les
plus les plus connus csu matra c java et
costumes traditionnels sont des costumes
extrêmement chatoyant du point de vue
des couleurs avec des coiffures
extraordinaire avec des offrandes
d'ailleurs en parlant d'offrandes le
spectacle s'est considéré par elle comme
une offrande aux français pour faire
connaître justement leur leur pays leurs
traditions
[Musique]
on passe maintenant à l'agenda plusieurs
rendez vous à noter pour les amateurs de
randonnée samedi à 15h30 rendez-vous à
l'abbaye de port royal des champs pour
une marche à la découverte de l'histoire
des religieuses des femmes qui ont
marqué la région du site de la ferme des
granges jusqu'à leur dernière demeure à
saint lambert du sport à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines ce
week-end une vingtaine d'activités sera
proposé pour l'événement sentez vous
sport aïkido parcours en fauteuil
roulant ou espace santé la rentrée
s'annonce sportive enfin pour les
amoureux de jazz le théâtre alphonse
daudet ouvre sa saison mardi 20
septembre avec mary hart mélody's plonge
dans le new york des années folles leur
castres fera revivre le jazz à haute
celui des années 20 et du début des
années 30 c'est la fin de cette fuite
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a très bon week-end
à tous
[Musique]